this is from the la times it says a
house committee late wednesday advanced
legislation
first introduced in 1989 that would
study the issue of awarding reparations
to this the descendants of american
slaves
um the house judiciary committee voted
along party lines to send a bill to the
house floor for the first time to create
a commission to study the legacy of
american slavery
of racist laws and how they affected
formerly enslaved people under
descendants the bill instructs the
13-person committee to
consider a national apology apology
and to recommend any appropriate
remedies to congress
um for slavery so this is a bill
this is a committee talking about a bill
to study to you know
there are a lot of steps still to go
through
and um this goes back to 1989 so this
idea has been out there for a long time
up until a couple of years ago i would
have said uh this is political posturing
it's not really going to happen but
i think we're at a point now where this
will happen i'll make that prediction
right now i think reparate
some kind of reparation policy will be
passed
uh it is with the the democrats having
total control of the government right
now
and white guilt being at its absolute
peak
um yeah i think it will happen
it's not going to be to the to the full
extent that
left-wing activists hope for but it'll
be something
let's look at a few clips here of um
lawmakers debating this first here is
democrat hakeem jeffries
arguing for reparations let's hear what
his case is
i'm not going to move on because after
slavery jim crow
and the rise of the kkk and the lynching
epidemic
and plessy versus ferguson and black
wall street
in 1921 destroyed why because black
prosperity
was viewed as a threat to white
supremacy so no
we're not simply going to move on
and when the great depression struck
african americans will hit the hardest
and we received the least amount of
support
why because yes southern dixiecrats
insisted that in the new deal
african americans would be excluded
while other americans were helped
excluded from social security because
most of us were domestic workers
or many of us and agricultural workers
excluded from social security
excluded from unemployment insurance
and excluded from the federally
subsidized loans and insured loans that
were issued so between 1934
and 1962 98
of the federally insured loans that were
issued by the federal government were
issued to white americans
okay rather than me responding to that
uh i'd rather hear from representative
burgess owens
who uh i i he he you could find the clip
online it's like five minutes long of
everything he has to say about this idea
of reparations well worth your time to
listen to we can't play the whole five
minutes so here's uh
here's a little bit of what burgess
owens had to say in response to this
idea
i'm looking forward to by the way
reparation when you take people's money
that they've earned is punishment it's
def
it's theft it's judgment
you're saying that because your skin
color you owe me that is not the
american way we're not racist people
this american country is based on
meritocracy
and i tell you anybody who's been in
sports or or military you guys get it
at the end of the day it's the character
it's resolved it's a loyalty that makes
a difference
the color of skin has nothing to do with
how we choose those people that we want
to trust move forward with
yeah that's that kind of sums it up
that's what it is it is um
punishment vengeance
that's why i say what what what is
greasing the wheels here
for this to actually happen is white
guilt white guilt at an all-time high
in this country especially on the left
but not just on the left this is
something that is being
drilled into kids heads from a very
young age
and it gets more and more intense as
they get older you get into a con into
college
and it is full-on cult-like brainwashing
but the idea is
if you're if you're white you're guilty
of these sins from the past you're you
are
you have unique ancestral guilt
as i always say it's a very religious
kind of idea this is their religion
the idea of inherited guilt only in this
case it is it is
racially inherited guilt like there's
guilt that
that flows in the in the bloodline for
white people
and this is an idea that many people
find very convincing and compelling
because it's been beaten to their heads
and that's why a lot of white people in
this country now would would submit to
this
having money taken out of their wallets
food taken out of their children's
mouths
to pay for a sin they didn't commit they
had nothing to do with
at all
now one thing that they that is rarely
clarified when we hear this idea of
reparations you heard when i was reading
from the la times article they talk
about
reparation for the descendants of of of
african slaves
well even that is a horrible idea but is
that is that really all you're talking
about so
we're going to before we pay reparations
to a black american first we're going to
make sure they actually are a descendant
of an african slave is that is that what
we're talking about
because that's going to exclude many
millions of black americans who live
here now and are not descendants of
of african slaves because their family
came here
more recently than that but if we're
doing that
okay so if we're if we are um
if we're if we're gonna single out the
descendants of african slaves
then are we also going to single out the
descendants of
slave owners
what about the people who uh white
people who came whose families came here
well after slavery had already been
abolished
like me for example my family my family
wasn't here when that was happening
my family's largely irish which means
not only did they not own slaves but
when they came here they faced
quite a lot of discrimination systemic
discrimination as well
do i get some kind of reparation for
that
i mean you you could easily make the
case that uh
when my answer my irish ancestors came
here they faced
discrimination systemic discrimination
against irish people
which was very common back then um and
if
in and you know that set them on a
certain path
and if it weren't for that i could be in
a totally different spot right now i
could be much richer much
much more well-off you know butterfly
effect and all that
you can make that case
but then if you're gonna do that then
you could really take
and you could trace it back and you
could find the misfortunes suffered by
their ancestors
tragedies that befell them oppression
they suffered
it would be very hard to find probably
anyone on earth
outside of like i don't know the royal
family
there are not very many people on earth
who um
do not have very real oppression
in their bloodline going back to their
ancestors
oppression persecution tragedy
suffering you know that that's common
for all people everywhere for all time
but
especially when you go back through
history well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content